[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 31 mai 2010 est
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 fit les invités versailles accueille
la 22e édition du mois molière du 1er au
30 juin 2010 est comme chaque année la
ville accueille 350 spectacle la plupart
gratuits l'occasion idéale de s'offrir
un avant goût du festival d'avignon
versailles plus est un journal gratuit
d'information locale qui va publier
enjoint son numéro 101 mensuel qui met
en valeur les talents les lieux et
l'histoire de la ville et enfin la
banque populaire val de france vient de
récompenser les talents de notre région
et notamment la brasserie de la vallée
de chevreuse qui a reçu cette année le
prix de la catégorie innovation
technologique mais partons au théâtre
avec versailles qui accueille donc cette
22e édition du mois molière du 1er au 30
juin 2017 c'est une véritable hommage à
la création théâtrale le mois molière
transforme la ville de versailles en
gigantesque théâtre à ciel ouvert avec
près de 350 spectacle la plupart
gratuits mélanie poker a rencontré son
créateur françois de mazières
françois de mazières bonjour un jour
cette année c'est la 22e édition du mois
molière 22e et 10
oui un deuxième édition cela fait tout
de même une longue histoire et beaucoup
de spectacle
vous pensiez que ça a duré aussi
longtemps a bien sûr et quand on crée un
festival c'est pas pour le voir
disparaître en essais ils perdent le
plus longtemps possible
surtout qu'il fonctionne bien il ya un
beau coup public aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'acteurs également ici au moins un
molière
oui et c'est une belle aventure que
va-t-on découvrir cette année des
nouveautés chaque année ces nouveautés
vous avez des créations qui sont
spécialement fait pour le mois molière
2017 comme par exemple actuellement une
répétition là à côté de nous d'une pièce
amphitryon de molière qui depuis est
rarement jouée qui est mise en scène par
stéphanie tesson et puis à côté vous
avez bien sûr d'aider reprise mais les
spectacles que je programme dans la
programmation va dire in la
programmation officielle
c'est toujours les spectacles très
récents qui ont au maximum un voire deux
ans d'ancienneté
il ya toujours beaucoup de théâtre mais
pas seulement vous mettez en avant
la musique de la danse et du cirque
c'est une volonté de mourir autre plus
de concerts ont été que de pièces de
théâtre parce que il ya une richesse
musicale exceptionnelle à versailles et
donc il suffit je vous dirais de se
pencher pour trouver ici des
propositions musicales de qualité parce
qu'il ya énormément de chorales parce
que vous savez le conservatoire à vos
questions régionales de versailles parce
que vous avez le centre de musique
baroque et puis parce que vous avez
aussi des gens qui veulent venir au
festival est ce que vous aimez chaque
année ces mails et les amateurs et les
professionnels
oui il ya bien sûr beaucoup de
spectacles de professionnels et ce qui
est à noter c'est que
un grand nombre de ces spectacles sont
gratuits ça je tiens ça parce que je
pense que contrainte financière ne doit
pas être un obstacle
alors il ya beaucoup de mesures qui
permettent au quotidien d'alléger cette
contrainte
il ya des tarifs réduits mais là pendant
le mois molière c'est les premiers
arrivés qui rentre dans certains
spectacles puis deux spectacles sont
payants bien sûr mais la logique ici aux
grandes écuries notamment si les
premiers arrivés et vous mettez aussi en
avant des troupes en résidence chez vous
notamment ceux qui ouvre le 1er juin
c'est le collectif voit des plumes bois
des plumes c'est un collectif assez
extraordinaire qui est autour d'une
personnalité très forte qui renie rien
qui est un metteur en scène comédien
remarquable comédien on peut le voir là
dans une pièce qui a été monté à partir
du roman de boulgakov magnifique roman
ou sur la vie de molière votre festival
si vous ouvrez les lieux emblématiques
oui la ville bien sûr parce que
versailles c'est une ville qui est
réputé dans le monde entier pour son
château mais aussi pour la beauté de ses
quartiers historiques
donc l'idée c'est vraiment d'essaimer
dans toute la ville il ya un 60 lieux de
spectacles dans les lieux historiques
mais aussi dans nos quartiers sociaux
parce que la culture dont elle est
partout elle est pour tous versailles
plus c'est un journal gratuit
d'information locale qui va publier en
juin son numéro 101 mensuel qui met en
valeur donc les talons les lieux de
l'histoire de la ville et nous recevrons
son directeur qui ont à l'avant merci
bonjour bonjour alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous de présenter un petit peu ce
magazine connu de tous les marseillais
mais pas forcément des habitants en
dehors de versailles donc c'est un
journal qui a 10 ans aujourd'hui sa
journée d'information gratuit donc c'est
un journal on trouve
dans l'est les commerçants et qu'on
trouve dans les parkings par exemple et
c'est vraiment un journal qui est fait
pour les versailles et c'est vraiment
des informations sur versailles est
toujours en amont on aime bien avoir les
informations avant tout le monde
donc nous on est vraiment en quête
d'informations dans tous les quartiers
et notre objectif c'est chaque mois
sortir un numéro avec des informations
qui vont étonner les versailles et et
kid mis en avant évidemment la ville
alors comment on fait pour un petit peu
à voir toutes ces informations on a un
réseau en un réseau d'habitants qui nous
a faim on a un réseau d'habitants on a
aussi notre petite information partout
que ce soit à la mairie que ce soit au
conseil général que ce soit un peu dans
tous les lieux publics mais aussi on a
une équipe rédactionnelle qui
travaillent et surtout ben voilà qui à
la recherche d'informations et on aime
bien évidemment trouver l'information
avant tout le monde et c'est ce qui fait
que le journal s'est pas un journal
c'est un google actualités c'est
vraiment un journal d accueil et d un
avro inédites qu'on trouve n'est pas
exactement d'accord et or qui écrit dans
ce journal c'est des habitants qui
s'essaie à l'écriture ou cd journalistes
qui viennent spécialement pour via des
deux il ya le directeur de la rédaction
c'est michel guibal un ancien
journaliste de france info
très connue donc c'est quelqu'un qui à
la retraite aujourd'hui et son passe
temps favori c'est de parler de
versailles
donc on a la chance de l'avoir on a
encore wernick ithurbide qui travaille
pour hanter les 218 qui est aussi
journaliste et qui fait toute la
rubrique people et on a des contacts
dans chaque quartier et qui écrivent
pour nous selon l'actualité et selon les
dossiers qu'on décide de traiter
donc chaque mois il n'y a pas de
difficulté à trouver des nouveaux sujets
on arrive à remplir les gendarmes
toujours on n'a jamais eu difficultés
pour remplir le journal non vraiment
versailles une actualité très riche et
puis surtout on parle de versailles mais
aussi on peut parler d orsay de saclay
de nuit en cours voilà l'objectif est de
parler vraiment au versailles et de
versailles mais aussi des alentours
oui c'est à dire que en fait les
habitants des autres villes peuvent
quand même lire votre journal
il ya ainsi mis l'internât il est
disponible sur le site internet mail et
sur la distribution il est distribué que
dans versailles chez les commerçants et
dans les parkings dans à peu près 140
160 points 2
de distribution du journal et le journal
est diffusé à 18 milles exemplaires et
la force du journal et c'est pour ça que
je ne veux pas changer de technique
c'est vraiment un journal que les gens
vont prendre donc ce n'est pas un
journal qui est dit mais dans les boîtes
aux lettres
c'est pas comme un prospectus est
vraiment un journal où il ya volonté de
le prendre et généralement en une
semaine
le mensuel est déjà épuisé alors là vous
allez fêter ses vous disant est
également le numéro sans qui ce qui va
devoir dans ce numéro 100 a basculé
ressent déjà on va remercier nos
partenaires qui nous aident depuis le
départ parce qu'on a vraiment des des
annonceurs qui sont là depuis le début
qu'il nous aide parce que c'est un
cheval gratuite il vit que par les
annonceurs et surtout on va voir
l'ancien rédacteur en chef nous a fait
le plaisir de vous nous montrez déjà la
couverture exactement dix ans 2007-2010
est oui c'est donc un journal qui a 10
ans donc on est très fiers et dans ce
journal aussi un peu spécial qui sera
plus épais qu'il ya plus de pages qui
sera qu'un meilleur un papier plus épais
aussi on va aussi en archives montré des
articles qui ont marqué les dix ans du
journal d'accord un peu une rétro qui
venait du meilleur de ce qu'on a fait
voilà parfait donc on rappelle
versailles plus chez les commerçants les
distributeurs ça peut être aussi les
kiosques que les commerçants les
parkings publics ont trouvé un peu par
contre si on le cherche on me trouve et
si on ne trouve pas ele parking
forcément dans la ville ces rachats ont
détruit tout le mois et autrement il ya
le site internet qui permet à versailles
puis ce point fr ben vous vous pouvez le
trouver en pdf parfait bon merci merci
beaucoup
donc maintenant nous allons parler de
bière avec la banque populaire val de
france qui viendrait compenser les
talons de notre région et notamment la
brasserie de la vallée de chevreuse
installé à beaune elle fabrique et
commercialise depuis 2008 la seule bière
artisanale des yvelines elle emploie 5
personnes et réalise 600000 euros de
chiffre d'affaires
miquel et demi d'euros a rencontré son
directeur emmanuel rey qui vient de
recevoir d'ailleurs le prix de la
catégorie innovation technologique
alors pour vous présenter l'histoire de
cette bière donc la brasserie la vallée
de chevreuse les créé en 2008
je me suis installé dans le parc naturel
d'un par choix essentiellement du cadre
de vie et
et j'avais à l'origine moi j'ai
découvert la bière je travaillais dans
le vin et j'ai fait des vinifications
bon un peu en france et puis j'ai fait
une vinification et l'année aux états
unis
et là j'ai découvert énormément de
deux bières artisanales et une habitude
de consommation également de ces
produits-là aux états unis avec des
bières vraiment très typé très original
très différentes les unes des autres et
c'est ce qui m'a donné un peu le goût de
cette aventure et qu'est-ce qu'elle a
cette bière de différents alors
elle agirait plutôt l on puisse qu'on a
une gamme en a une dizaine de bières
donc on a des bières qui sont très
légères assez fruité avec peu d'amertume
on a des bières assez forte assez amer
on a des bières brunes on a des bières
qu'on élève en fût de chêne on a des
biens au café on a toutes sortes de
bières et c'est distribuer ou ses bières
on notre distribution s'est
essentiellement sur le territoire de la
vallée de chevreuse et en région
parisienne
pour l'essentiel des caves à vins des
caves à bière des épiceries fines des
supérettes des magasins bio un petit peu
de restauration également votre
entreprise est seulement ici à bonnel
alors on a notre site de production sur
bonnel on a un site de stockage
également sur lee moore voilà on l'est
on a été très vite à l'étroit
donc on a cherché à s'agrandir au petit
à petit présentez-nous un petit peu ses
locaux ils sont comment ces locaux ici
abonnés donc là on a on a deux deux
travées dans un bâtiment que nous nous
la commune
une première travée qui nous sert sur
toute la partie production au sens
brassage et fermentation donc on utilise
au départ des des malts d'orge
donc on concassant aux médias nina
laitages et ensuite par gravité décembre
dans notre
une pub pour le lan partagent donc la
préparation du mou et ensuite on fait
donc fermenté les bières et après on a
une deuxième partie du local qui est
consacrée au conditionnement en
bouteilles votre bière a été primé
récemment qu'est ce que ça vous fait
ouais on a été primé plusieurs fois au
concours général agricole on a été primé
à bruxelles également
donc c'est toujours assez flatteur et
puis ça vient récompenser aussi tout un
travail de parts de recherche sur les
recettes est également un travail sur la
régularité et la constance des produits
qu'on peut fournir
donc voilà c'est assez valorisant quel
est l'avenir de cette entreprise
à l'heure actuelle on est quand même en
recherche de
locaux pour s'agrandir parce que là on
touche plus on refuse énormément de
ventes
idéalement on voudrait rester sur le
territoire du parc naturel après il
faudra aura trouvé mais toujours dans
les yvelines
il ya une idée également de partir vers
l'étranger de produire encore plus ici
pour l'exporter à l'étranger
alors on a eu quelques demandes
effectivement à l'exportation auxquelles
on n'a pas pu répondre faute de capacité
à produire
donc on espère en déménageant dégager de
nouvelles capacités pour pouvoir
éventuellement répondre à des demandes à
l'export web alors je vous rappelle le
mois molière à versailles avec des
représentations tout le mois de juin la
brasserie de chevreuse donc récompensé
pour sa bière locale et le magazine
versait plus magazine gratuit qui va
sortir bientôt son 100ème numéro
voilà c'est la fin de ce cette fuite est
invité merci de votre fidélité
replay sur notre site internet tv fil 78
points comme et sur notre application
à bientôt
[Musique]